- I, I think of really
cute round animals and
- I think of like soy sauce.
- Ok.
- So I don't know how it's gonna go.
(cheery music plays)
- The coins that Meowth had in Pokemon.
- Wow, like, the one on his head.
- The one on his head.
- Rice puff?
- Smells fried.
- Oh, that's good, fried is good.
(crunching)
- I was not expecting that.
- I like that.
- That's like sweet and
savory at the same time.
- It's like a spicey rice cracker.
- If you've ever had Pops cereal,
it's just a big Pops.
- Ya this kind of just seems like
an airplane snack.
- Ya, like, their version of
the two pack of Ritz crackers.
- Ya, ya, ya!
- I've had these before,
and I love 'em.
- I like the name, already.
- You can eat the inner wrapper,
which is a lot of fun.
- Why are you supposed to eat paper?
I don't understand.
- They're too big to suck on.
- Ya
(both laugh)
- This is a really good way to
shut up your kids.
'Cause you feed them this,
there's no way that they can
have a conversation.
- I think this is what my mom was doing.
- That's like, very chewy.
- No, no.
- Ooh, this looks like twigs.
- Those are little fish.
- What?
- See that eye, lookin' at you.
- Right?
- That looks like sardines.
Oh my God.
- Basically fish.
- Holy shit.
- Or it could be an eel.
- That was damn good.
- Mmm.
- It's like salty.
- Mmm!
- Not bad at all.
- It tastes like a fish tank smells.
- This like legitimately
tastes good together.
This is so surprising.
- You don't want to eat
these before a date though.
- Oh my God!
(excitedly squeals)
- Here's something I
can get on board with.
- He looks so happy
when you turn his head.
- Also, a piggy bank.
- Could you just see,
a little chubby baby,
like carrying this around.
- No.
- I just can't get into my candy.
- What child with man strength
can do this?
(slurps)
- Wha wha whamp
(both slurp and laugh)
(slurps)
- Delicious.
- Ya, they come to my desk
and just see these everywhere.
- It's like, "I had an episode!".
- What the fuck
does the pig have to do
with jell-o snacks?
- They're both jiggly.
- Delicious.
- Ya!
- I actually liked everything.
- The crackers, were a dark horse,
I really enjoyed them.
- Very understated, but very delicious.
- There were some weird
combinations going on.
- Ya.
- Fish and almonds.
- On sight, I was like, no.
But taste, yes.
- I feel like it's gotta be a really
fun place to eat.
- Ya!
- 'Cause like, there's some crazy,
not just like combinations,
but the presentation
of some of this, is pretty extraordinary.
(squeaky hinge sound plays)